you know another guy who's more
conservative than joe biden or jeff
flake for that matter
or a lot of the people we were told were
conservatives before the last several
years
kanye west kanye west oh my gosh when
kanye first kind of came onto the
political scene started saying political
things
so how many sophisticated conservatives
said oh my gosh stop it
go away kanye we don't want to hear from
you oh kind uh this is so embarrassing
we're fancy people we go to think tanks
and eat boxed lunches
and we sip chablis we we don't need to
be listening from kanye how embarrassing
well guess what turns out kanye west is
more conservative
than the vast majority of elected
republicans because he actually
understands what
what the problem is and he's willing to
go places
that a lot of conservatives would not so
you remember nick cannon he was that
kind of
ex-child star i guess he's still on some
tv shows or something nick cannon made
these comments a
few weeks ago where he was he was
criticizing the jews and he was calling
white people animals and saying they
didn't have souls and
really toxic stuff he almost got
cancelled for it except
because his racism was directed to white
people and jews it didn't really stick
and
i think he was able to keep most of his
employment so kanye west decides to go
on this show not to agree with nick
cannon
but to show him issues with his
political
views and to to try to bring him over
to a more conservative point of view and
he focused in
with brilliant precision on
planned parenthood in 50 years
there's 20 there's been 22 million
over 22 million 500 000
black people aborted
strategically and on purpose
planned parenthood was set up and placed
in minority
communities to
kill black people you're talking about
uh
when margaret sanger the originator of
planned parenthood at the time
because a lot of people when when you
say things like that to in their defense
they say well planned parenthood today
is a different organization but
here we go margaret sanger the founder
of planned parenthood
was an avowed racist whose goal was to
reduce the black population
in america and she succeeded 80 percent
of abortion clinics
in america are in minority neighborhoods
over 22 million
500 000 black babies have been aborted
in 50 years
so those numbers are undeniable
statistics i guess
sometimes we can use statistics it when
they when they
serve our purposes but we should be we
should be careful about statistics
because statistics get manipulated by
social scientists but those numbers are
hard to deny we we do know the number of
babies who have been killed we do know
that planned parenthood was
strategically placed in minority
neighborhoods we do know that margaret
sanger was a racist you know obviously
that word now has kind of lost all
meaning but whatever meaning it once had
certainly she qualifies there's a quote
that goes around all the time for
margaret sanger that says we don't want
word to go out that we want to
exterminate the negro population
and what the left responds to that is
they'll say oh she was
she was being ironic in a letter that
she was writing to someone
and there i guess there's some validity
to that there she may have been denying
that even in her quote
but you don't just need to read that
quote read woman in the new race
read all of her other writings she was
an avowed eugenicist
who viewed certain undesirable
populations
as being sub-human and she wanted to
eradicate them and that included
what she viewed to be lesser races and
that included
people who had mental problems who she
suggested be snuffed out through
abortion
all of that is undeniable and
the left obviously doesn't want to talk
about it many people on the right don't
want to talk about it you know fancy
conservatives kanye west is willing to
talk about it
who's more conservative jeff flake or
kanye west
kanye kanye is kanye west is
even though he's got a lot of kooky
things that he says he's more
conservative than i would estimate 70
of elected republicans in the country
and he's willing to go out and use some
cultural power like
another president that we have who
happened to be a tv star and a cultural
icon
like going over and talking to nick
cannon another
former tv star another cultural figure
willing to engage on that level that's a
very conservative thing to do
and what's the alternative what's the
alternative you know we've been joking
about all the conspiracy theories going
around the internet trump was asked
about this they said do you believe in
these conspiracy theories
he said what conspiracy theory because
the theory is that there's a satanic
group of pedophiles
cannibals that are trying to destroy the
country they thought like well satanic
let's see the left is uh burning down
churches
and pedophiles they're i just saw a
photo of
bill clinton hanging out with jeffrey
epstein getting a massage and
cannibals i saw risa astley i need human
brains on cnn
yeah sounds about right yeah sound i
don't is that a conspiracy theory i can
name all the people who are doing those
things
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the
full episode linked in the description
or download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you